[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making those headlines
with the columnist carol malone and the
political editor at the liverpool echo
liam thorpe so welcome to both of you
nice to see you both and you will be
both with us until midnight so it's good
to have you here
so first of all let's take a look at
what's on the front pages then and the
guardian leads with a report from the
city of mariopol it describes conditions
there as medieval following what it
calls relentless shelling from russian
forces
chelsea football club's billionaire
owner roman abramovic has been
sanctioned by the government and told he
has a blood on his hands that makes the
front of the metro
it's the same story for the mirror with
their headline blood brothers
the eye reports the governments accused
him of destabilizing ukraine by
supplying steel which may have been used
to build russian tanks
the times also leads with abramovich
mentioning britain is the first country
to sanction the billionaire
the sun says chelsea football club could
go bust as a result of the russian
invasion their headline skinski
the telegraph reports the british public
will be asked to offer their homes to
tens of thousands of ukrainian refugees
and more than half of ukraine's economy
has shut down and infrastructure worth a
hundred billion dollars has been
destroyed during the invasion that's on
the front of the financial times
and just a reminder by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out those
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
but let's uh bring in uh now columnist
carol malone and the political editor at
the liverpool echo liam thorpe so good
to see you both welcome um let's kick
off with the front page of the mirror
shall we liam a lot of the front pages
tomorrow devoted to britain becoming the
first country to sanction
roman abramovich and ministers have
accused him of having blood of his hands
because of what they say are his links
to putin hence um the headline in the
mirror blood brothers and i know that
you interviewed the prime minister today
it's not only uh beth rigby that's
talked to boris johnson today but you
too did a talk with him and you talked
about this so what did he tell you
that's right yeah that barbara johnson
was in uh merseyside today he was
visiting a shipyard to make a separate
announcement but we obviously asked him
about a number of uh subjects related to
the the ongoing uh crisis in ukraine and
it was the big breaking news at the
moment at the exact moment was that uh
roman abramovich the owner of chelsea
had
had just been sanctioned had his assets
frozen and and of course all the all the
impacts that come with that in terms of
chelsea football club um so i asked the
prime minister why he had made this
decision now um
i pointed to the fact that there had
been calls for action against mr
bramovic for some time including in the
house of commons
and he said that there had been ongoing
investigations into mr abramovic and his
ties with the putin regime and that they
just got to the point now where they had
crossed the threshold
to make this to take this action now
they were satisfied that he was indeed
um you know did indeed have links to
putin's regime and as you've just
pointed out before there was potentially
benefiting had benefited financially and
the other lines that have since come out
subsequently come out is that you know
um he may have been producing steel that
may potentially have been used in
russian tanks that are committing you
know some of these uh atrocities in in
ukraine so um
um boris johnson said that the it was
quite interesting point really he said
that in the uk we don't we we can't move
as quickly on things like seizing assets
as in other countries and this is
something that he wants to
uh wants to speed up with the economic
crime bill which has come into the
commons next week uh so he said this
process would have been faster after
that um although other people obviously
his critics believe that he just hasn't
moved quickly enough on this but he has
moved today and obviously the massive
ramifications for uh mr abramovic and
chelsea well yeah and if we look at the
metro um carol blood in his hands is is
their headline in fact it's exactly the
same headline on the eye as well i mean
how important is this speed aspect i
mean some might say that these are very
rich people they've got uh
the money to afford uh some really good
advisors and lawyers and they could
shift their assets they've been warnings
of sanctions for some time
what you're exactly right anna there
have been ones they've had a 10-day head
start the oligarchs on this to get their
money out of the country you know the eu
was already frozen assets
and imposed travel bans we have been
very slow to do that and i don't know
why it's that hard for us if you have
already done it um so yeah but i think
it's a really important step um but you
know targeting oligarchs is something
that makes headlines it's not
necessarily the most effective way to
wreck russia's economy or it's war
machine you know the most effective
thing is is to to limit moscow's access
to the foreign exchange reserves that
they exist to protect um against they
exist to protect against an attack on
the ruble that would hurt russia more
than the oligarchs this is a this is
something we're doing to kind of to make
a point but to be honest i think a lot
of them say in this country they've had
a 10-day head start to get their money
out many of them already will have
they're not multi-billionaires for
because they're not clever they will
have they will have done already that
but i just you know hitting banks and
financial institutions will have a
bigger impact um you know but the
problem is
seizures take time and and you know we
didn't move fast enough and and maybe
it's going to take a lot more time
before these things actually start to
bite there's an interesting story in the
in the telegraph business of tomorrow
tonight where it says that that russia
could actually default on its repayments
within days now if that happens that
would be the first time they've
defaulted on a payment since 1917 since
the end of the bolshev bolshevik
revolution so this would be this this
would show that they're starting to be
hit but i'm just not sure you know can i
i just want to say it
sanctions
that don't necessarily
enforce a leadership change or a policy
change sorry to rush you carol we're
just we're a bit squeezed in this
section and i did want to get on to what
the implications might be for chelsea
liam what's your thought on this i mean
they're not allowed to sell any more
tickets for games their merchandise shop
is closed they'll be unable to buy or
sell players on the transfer market and
there are all sorts of restrictions now
they're kind of in limbo aren't there
what does it mean for the future of the
club
oh it's in total limbo you know there's
reports coming out of chelsea today that
the players are understandably extremely
unsettled you know you've got to feel
for
staff members there who are worried
about their jobs as well as you say you
know the um the club shop closed they're
going to be limited in what they can
spend on travel to to matches which
particularly with with upcoming games in
europe is is is obviously a huge concern
um you know you you probably wouldn't be
surprised to think the manager thomas
tucker will be considering his future
you know this is a club that won the
champions league very recently and that
thomas duke was the man the best manager
in europe you know things were going
very swimmingly for them i think you
know we've discussed on this program
before football needs to take a long
hard look at itself roman abramovich has
been
you know in charge of chelsea for 19
years and and football's never really
paid much attention to him um the the
world cup was held in russia in 2018
it's going to be held in qatar in 2022
football for a long time has just looked
the other way to these controversial
figures and it's it shouldn't have taken
a war for this to be looked at more
closely okay we're going to we're going
to take a break i can see you nodding
there carol and so many issues that we
can revisit again in at 11 but let's
take a break right now and coming up the
economic impact of the invasion of
ukraine that's coming up
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight columnist carol
malone and political editor at the
liverpool echo liam thorpe so welcome
back to both of you and carol we're
going to kick off this section with the
front page of the daily telegraph
because their headline is an interesting
one it says british public to be asked
to take in refugees so what's the
telegraph saying about what's being
proposed
this they're going to ask people as you
just said to take in refugees it's going
to it's it's
yeah i mean and i'm sure there are there
will be thousands of members of the
british public that will rally to this
court because i think this this nation
has been
utterly devastated touched whatever by
what is happening there but you know to
me this is this is the sign of a home
office that has utterly failed to do its
job you know they've got
it strikes me that that while i know the
british public will respond to this it
strikes me that they're trying to force
responsibility for for taking in
refugees onto the british public it is
the government's responsibility to
provide accommodation for the refugees
to get them to get them sorted yes the
british public will rally but this is
not a solution and and one of the things
was that the refugees have to stay with
whoever they would be housed with for
someone for a minimum of six months
that's quite a big ask for a lot of
people for a lot of families so for me
it just seems to me like they're they're
slightly shifting responsibility onto a
public that they know
um are devastated by this crisis and
want to help but it should be literally
you know we haven't we have a home
office that is utterly inept they have
not been prepared for this they knew it
was coming they you know they treat what
they have done is shambolic and and it
shamed our country actually what they
have done with refugees and now they're
saying okay you want to look after you
look at them and that's not the way it
should be well yes and the paper says
that ministers are going to launch a
hotline on a web page where individuals
charities businesses and community
groups will be able to offer rooms to
refugees who have no family links in the
uk what do you make of what carol said
do you think she's right that it's it's
basically the home office putting the
responsibility on to members of the
public that should be their own
responsibility
so i agree with carol that the home
office has been an absolute shambles and
has created a sort of kafka nightmare
for refugees fleeing a a a
a devastating conflict we've seen some
of the the rigid ramifications they were
put in on um visa applications are just
just cruel to be honest um for people
who have left i'm not sure i fully agree
on the point about people taking in
numbers because that is happening all
over europe just because of the sheer
scale of people coming in and i know
that people in this country do want to
help i pushed the prime minister on this
point today actually saying that
actually there was a lot of people
saying we do want to help we do want to
offer our houses up but because of the
miserly scheme that was being offered by
the uk government which i i believe was
actually trying to limit the number of
people coming in that there just wasn't
that option so i i agree that on in in
principle you know the home office in
the government should look after
refugees but i think it's it's
understandable in this particular crisis
that we're going to have to see people
you know opening their doors and i think
many will okay and carol we've got very
little time but i do want to take in the
front page of the financial times a
reminder of what's going on on the
ground in ukraine they say half of
ukraine's economy shut down as mario
paul counts wars human costs we've only
got about 20 seconds or so but it's a
reminder of the horror that continues
yeah
the paper said that assets worth a
hundred billion dollars have been
destroyed already in ukraine since the
invasion started and already there was a
huge source of money among people people
were attacking each other today in
maripov for food they don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
power you know they were actually using
snow was drinking water the other day so
so they're in a mess it is it is a
humanitarian and a financial catastrophe
and there'll be plenty more of that that
we will talk about at the top of the
hour at 11 i'm very pleased to say you
will be with us until about quarter to
12. so for the moment carol and liam
thanks very much indeed